so here is scherzer we talked about it
off at the top but when he took the ball
here for his dodger debut just an
incredible environment that he talked
about really feeding off of in his first
game in dodger blue he's a high energy
guy to begin with especially when he
takes them out i mean
trey turner talks about he goes when
he's not pitching obviously he's fun
loving guy but all of a sudden there's a
switch that just he triggers the day
he's pitching he doesn't even like to be
touched like don't touch me on the days
i'm pitching
there's a line driving the center field
for a base hit and that's going to get
past bellinger and roll to the wall
nimmo arrives at second base with a
lead-off double
pops this one up on the left side of the
infield max muncie making the start
there today his second one this year
alonzo muscles one into shallow center
field that turner will put away all
right back-to-back soft outs after the
lead-off double emotes second two gone
and a three-one pitch to michael
conforto as a fastball left over the
plate hit to right field but taylor's
there
and that's the ending former dodger rich
hill on the mound at dodgers stadium
where he had a lot of success as a
member of the los angeles dodgers
hill in his career at dodger stadium as
a 275 era and it's no balls one strike
on the dodgers second baseman oh let's
turn her off to a start for the dodgers
and a fly ball to left field dominic
smith he's going back to the wall and
against the wall
it is gone
off the top of the wall a home run
for trey turner his 19th of the year he
now has hit in six consecutive games and
he is 11 for 21 and the dodgers take a
one to nothing lead don't leave him
hanging trey don't leave him hanging
the dodgers with a one to nothing lead
and here's this fella pujol
drives the first one that he sees the
deep right center field pujols goes deep
first pitch two nothing
shot out of a cannon to right center
field for his 15.
career home run 677.
he said it before we'll say it again
there's something different about the
sound when albert pujols hits it really
well
push bunt
straight back to hill he has time and
throws out taylor went away
smith at first and one out and bellinger
lifts one out to right and conforto is
there
two out
let's hit in the air toward right
shallow near the line conforto angles to
his left he's under it makes a
two-handed catch scherzer is retired
and the inning has completed
down in a fast ball and scherzer gets
his second strikeout of the game
back to the novelist spot here chases a
change up for strike three and his
struggles continue two and two on alonso
scherzer out of the stretch
comes home and strikes him out getting a
chase on the slider and the mets leave
another man in scoring position
hill age 41 against pujols age 41
the first match up
of pitcher and hitter this old
when bartolo colon was pitching for the
mets at age 43
and ichiro suzuki was hitting for the
marlins at age 42. ah that's a good one
that's sliced past the mound but with
pujols running plenty of time for mcneil
to throw him out
pop fly into left
aj pollock cruises on to put it away
now the one two max shares are set at
the chest and delivers
did he go around
yep which was down and in smith is down
and out
2-2
got him a fastball is by vr to finish
off the fourth
taylor oh for one he bounced back to
hill in his first played appearance on a
3-2 he hits it in the air to center
field nemo back to the track at the wall
there it goes
third solo shot of the day this one from
taylor gets a ball up in the zone away
puts a good swing on it stays on his
head down
drives it out to center field brandon
nimmo bid to second base twice
doubled in the first singled and stole a
base in the third inning left leg kick
the pitch
that's drifted toward the right field
corner it's deep down the line if it's
fair it's gone it's gone it hit the foul
pole it's a home run brandon nimmo
turned on a pitch that cut over the
inside half of the plate and nimmo just
ripped it down the right field line he
bounces it off the foul pole and the
mets are on the board and now it's right
on the plate of jd davis with two out of
the bases loaded as it was in the eighth
inning last night
[Applause]
he struck him out got a fast ball by him
to strand the bases loaded
four seeger takes a walk the bases are
loaded and nobody out well here's chris
taylor on a payoff taylor takes ball
four and the dodgers lead 4-1 on the
third consecutive walk from miguel
castro here's familia here where the
bases loaded on to face will smith
and he pops one up on the infield
infield flywheel called the batter is
out
and mcneal squeezes it and that's the
first out of the inning
and bellinger pops one up
into shallow right field tagging at
third is pollock in his conforto to make
the catch pollock is not gonna come
and conforto throws it to the plate on
the fly that's the second out well you
hear the announcement of justin turner
to pinch hit with the bases loaded two
out
[Applause]
sicker pull down to third handled by j.d
davis goes to second for the fourth side
retired heavy lifting by jres familia
comes into the bases loaded and nobody
out and allows no further scoring
laid off the 3-2 slider in the mets of a
two-out base runner for alonso
and alonso lifts one out to left field
it's deep back goes pollock to the
warning track at the wall and it's off
the top and over for a home run
his second of the series is 28th of the
year and the mets are right back in and
it's 4-3 la
not going and nimo flies one out to left
chasing pollock back in front of the
warning track he makes the catch
pillar tagging he's going to try for a
second and the ball gets away and he's
safe
a base it could tie the game mcneal his
last two at bats doubled down the right
field line and then walked and scored in
front of alonzo's home run in the
seventh
and jansen gets him with the fastball
for the second out
malar still at second pete alonso is due
up here it comes
he went around jackson slams the door
striking out pete alonso then putting
the finishing touches on the ninth
consecutive win
[Applause]